[Musica]
ma io vi devo raccontare
che cosa vuol dire per me
camminare è vero
a piedi
330 chilometri in mezzo ai boschi alla
natura a città meravigliose incontri
stupendi e stato bellissimo mi sono
arricchito però come sempre come in
tutti i cammini si prende sempre
qualcosa dal dal cammino ma devo fare un
piccolo passo indietro del perché ho
iniziato a camminare in tanti mi
chiedono perché cammini fatti i fatti
tuoi dico spesso ma alle volte invece
rispondo con un piccolo aneddoto
festivalbar qualcuno si ricorderà una
bella manifestazione significava tanto
ma salire su quel palco era era
emozionante ma tanto emozionante molto
io ero già stato su dei palchi
importanti anche se ero ragazzino avevo
magari 22 23 anni e mi è capitato gli
mtv days di avere anche 100mila persone
urlanti davanti e direi sulle mani e
questi mettevano sulle mani mi chiedevo
perché però era bello forte
e tanto nel dietro le quinte si respira
sempre un'aria di emozione di tensione
io ero un ragazzino avevo il mio
asciugamano che cercavo di strizzare per
togliere un po di emozione ma c'era
tanta emozione tanta ero dietro le
quinte a un certo punto vedo tom jones
che si sta preparando sarebbe salito lui
con per primo cielo lì a fianco che mi
guarda con gli occhi mi punta io
mi sforzo perché comunque cerco di
prendere un attimino un equilibrio non
mi guarda e frasi dios rousteing sperato
prima volta
se non si vede si se sia la prima volta
un fotografo ci fa facevano foto si
facciamo una foto della giacca bianca lo
abbraccio facciamo una foto ea una riga
di fondo tinta marrone qui così
protoghesi veri tolgo mi pulisco tous al
tetto e lui mi dice
respira è la parola all'arena di verona
dice salvetti michelle hunziker e marco
magrini presentano al festivalbar si
sale sul palco e si fa tutta la prima
parte una sorta di apnea io non so non
sapevo chi fosse al posto mio
a dire le cose che dicevo eppure
funziona va però avevo bisogno di
respirare
passa qualche anno
conosco una ragazza mi ci metto insieme
e le dico chiaramente aveva un estate
libera e le dico io però tra una
settimana vado a fare il cammino di
santiago e lei felicissima mi vengo
anch'io e io felicissimo le dico ok
vieni con me partiamo le aveva pochi
giorni purtroppo e quindi facciamo un
bel pezzo circa 250 chilometri del
cammino di santiago dove io le racconto
tutta la mia vita lei mi racconta la sua
e ci parliamo ci raccontiamo e devo
averle detto delle cose talmente
assurde che stiamo ancora insieme quindi
abbiamo ancora delle cose da raccontarci
siamo tornati anche l'anno successivo
quindi nel 2006 a concludere il cammino
di santiago lì è partita la mia passione
è per lei e per i cammini quindi li e
l'inizio di tutto quanto il primo giorno
è arrivato un ragazzo che ha iniziato a
parlarmi parlarmi parlarne a raccontarmi
che lui sapeva che lui faceva spirituale
1 spirituale e faccio io a quello perché
dice ora è basten mollami e poi
continuare mi diceva sì perché puoi
pensare la magia le cose ma a molla mie
cose ti faccio un regalo mi dice prima
di affrontare 250 km ecco queste sono
per te mi regala due pietre
cioè io sto per camminare con uno zaino
per dei chilometri tu mi regali 2
zavorra e questo metaforicamente mi ha
fatto pensare moltissimo infatti ci sono
degli oggetti che vanno lasciati a casa
che non servono sul cammino
assolutamente non te ne accorgi te ne
accorgi solo mentre cammini quando ti
fanno male alle spalle si dice anche usa
gli oggetti che ti servono non lasciarti
usare dagli oggetti che non ti servono e
questo è fondamentale che ho adesso sono
arrivato ad avere anche solo quattro
chili più l'acqua quindi un cambio solo
un paio di calze un pantaloncino una
maglietta che lava tutte le sere un
sacco a pelo un asciugamani know una
saponetta uno spazzolino da denti lo so
perché ogni volta che si parte tutte le
mattine si fa
cos'e dimenticato e quindi sulle cose
che ho nel mio zaino qui sono arrivato
anche con la tenda un saio il cammino
successivo nel 2016 saliscendi
saliscendi sali e scendi che ti fai due
matic e così proprio perché nel vero
senso della parola forza di salire i
muscoli diciamo cambiano ecco e comunque
ero ancora sbagliato perché ero ancora
comunque un po all'inizio della mia
carriera da camminatore diciamo così
quindi zaino preso in uno di quei
supermercati abbastanza un po così e
magliette di cotone che dopo circa dieci
minuti che ce l'hai addosso e se partito
le devi strizzare e comunque dopo un po
prendono anche quel profumo di
pellegrino tipico proprio bello forte ma
soprattutto appunto magari le scarpe le
calze di spugna quelle che usa vi alle
superiori
bianche un po slabbrati né non poi così
è son lì son come le metti vesciche
assicurate solo dopo un po si impara a
metter le calze tecniche mettere per
esempio ogni sera degli unguenti
qualcosa la mattina si mette la vaselina
io mi ci porti un vasetto di vaselina
alcuni che fanno il cammino di santiago
vogliono avere le vesciche io no io non
voglio avere mare io voglio stare bene
non voglio avere assolutamente nessun
problema mi metto la vaselina sui piedi
e così ma soprattutto appunto camminando
camminando questo zayed avevo comprato e
sali e scendi e sali e scendi e sa che
poi tra l'altro nei paesini della
liguria ci sono questi anziani che fanno
su e giù e ti superano cioè tu stai
andando e dice io sono un camminatore
vedi questi che pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
hanno fatto la spesa sono abituati io
avevo sto zaino che continuava i lacci
si simulava non c'è andavano giù poi di
fianco si sballa vada sotto quindi io
devo sistemarli un pochino io dovevo
chiuderle in questo modo slacciava di
nuovo eri toccavo e sistemava andava di
nuovo giù e scendeva quello ritiravo su
allora poi di nuovo ancora riallacciamo
poi rimettevo su promettevo le cose sono
sono stato un precursore dei balletti di
tik tok ho iniziato camminando a fare
delle robe un po così la gente mi
guardava diciamo a poraccio e l'ho
scelto pensa un po che roba poi ho
cambiato zain si impara lo zaino è più
tecnico e va comunque si va a vado vado
vado vado vado e mi sono per la prima
volta portato anche un amaca piccola
così molto comoda la prima volta sul
cammino degli innamorati mi sono
piazzato tra due alberi e c'era uno
strapiombo di 100 metri con ha
ovviamente era proprio un balconcino
comodo lo sciabordio dell'acqua da sotto
che si sentiva io ero in un hotel 5
stelle e ho dormito lì sotto le stelle
non c'è niente di più bello è stupendo
dormire all'aria aperta nel nulla più
totale con questi questi suoni la
seconda volta invece ha dormito in un
bosco il bosco di no
li potete immaginare come possa essere
dormire da soli in un bosco il bosco di
notte ti parla ti senti
ti ammazzo ti ammazzo morirai
aghi addosso ecco volevo cercare un modo
e infatti ho passato la notte così
nella macaè comodo per l'amor del cielo
ma così perché non è da noi sono un
cittadino ma cosa vado a dormire nel
bosco ma perché ho scelto però è
piaciuta anni successivi che ancora ho
dormito
fuori vi racconto quest'altro cammino
che ho fatto pochi mesi fa che il
cammino degli dei e che va da bologna
spense sono circa 130 chilometri e mi
sono portato alla tenda era in completa
autonomia e mi sono divertito appunto di
nuovo a era già successo altre volte ma
questa questa ve la voglio raccontare
dormo in questa valle straordinaria
bellissima non c'è niente davanti a me
se non un prato gigantesco che arriva
alla collina che ho di fronte dove vedo
degli alberi un bosco gigantesco dietro
di me sono protetto da da una una
casetta abbandonata quindi anche il
vento se mi sentivo bene mi sentivo
protetto diciamo ferraro da solo a nel
nulla più totale è un certo punto
durante la notte sento delle urla
belluine
ma che mi sveglio ovviamente
grida femminili chiaramente delle urla
di una donna ok nel nulla
tiro fuori la testa guardo per l'altra
parte tipo una sorta di lucina ma non so
se una lucina non se sono ancora mezzo
addormentato che cosa sarà quella roba
da un fuoco ma stanno facendo un rituale
satanico e un sabba sanno squartando una
vera cioè io poi sono dotato di molta
fantasia quindi nel senso poteva essere
veramente di tutto c'è poteva essere
un'arpia che ti sta lavorando sopra mi
avrebbe preso con i suoi artigli e
portato mondo poteva essere un lupo non
so se poteva essere un cinghiale
poteva essere tutto poteva essere
talmente tanto nella mia testa che mi
sono rimesso i tappi ho chiuso e mi sono
rimesso a dormire
ho dormito benissimo perché in quel caso
era la mia paura non farmi dormire non
sono lo sapevo non so poi mi hanno detto
che poteva essere un cervo tra l'altro
quindi proprio niente ma in quel momento
non sapevo per mero nulla però ho detto
non mi faccio sopraffare dalla paura la
paura genera paura e quindi io non ho
avuto paura mi sono addormentato punto
fine bellissimo da lì altro insegnamento
che mi sono portato siamo invece a
questo cammino questo questo questo
arriva la cosa bella di camminare è
proprio quella che sei da solo con te
stesso io cammino da solo poi si
racconto faccio i miei filmati che è una
cosa che mi piace magari qualcuno ha
visto qualcosa cerco sempre di essere
leggero divertente ma dietro cerco
sempre di nascondere un minimo di
profondità tra virgolette atteggiamento
delle virgolette molto grandi però nel
senso che cosa ti insegna ti insegna che
segna a guardarti dentro ti insegna a
respirare meglio ti insegna a sentire i
profumi
dei posti che stai attraversando
disegna con lentezza a guardare la
natura e riconoscere ogni foglio ogni
ogni sasso ogni tronco e poi scollinare
andare dall'altra parte ed entrare in un
mondo completamente nuovo che in
macchina sembra tutto uguale sembra una
grande macchia non non ti accorgi della
differenza e metaforicamente la stessa
cosa dentro di te quando vai veloce non
ti accorgi se cambia qualcosa in testa
c'è qualcosa che che magari è cresciuto
che ha preso una profondità diversa non
te ne accorgi invece rallentando tutto e
sei costretto a rallentare rallentando
tutto inizia piano piano proprio a come
dire avere una consapevolezza diversa
anche di quello che ti sta intorno
all'ora arrivano le persone meravigliose
che incontri ho incontrato una vecchina
che mi ha fatto
distrutto proprio son magone solo a
pensarci mi raccontava che nei suoi 90
anni aveva sofferto ma che comunque era
felice perché dai pronipoti piccole cose
minuscole ma che diventano gigantesche
ed enormi e diciamo camminare
e un suono anche quindi c'è il profumo
c'è il suono dei tuoi passi che stai
andando ai cammini io vorrei invitarvi a
fare due passi con me venite venite come
quasi quasi fate un giro insieme a mary
chiedo di di chiudere gli occhi chiudete
gli occhi e piano piano ascoltateli
suono dei miei passi tra l'altro
qua vicino
non molto lontano da qui vedete tutti
gli occhi e lasciatevi trasportare da
dal suono dei passi
del bastone ogni tanto
è il vostro respiro
provate ad ascoltare
questo mantra che mi accompagna e
accompagna un camminatore per tante ore
al giorno
state camminando e avete
avete del pensiero
[Applauso]
ed è bello ogni tanto ascoltare questi
pensieri è stata con giochi chiusi e
godetevi questo ritmo
basso del respiro del vostro cuore
e se vengono dette insieme
belli
condivide come faccio io
[Applauso]
[Musica]